صار لنا شيء اربعه ايام من وقت الزلزال
بالليل طلعنا الصبح بكير وقعدنا هون
وشعلنا نار اول شيء هلا اول شيء الحمد لله
على سلامتكم
عيله وحده قرايبين يعني في عالم انهدت
بيوتها عملنا لها هاي الخيام هون وقعدوا
فيها ليش ما عندكم خيم نظاميه وصلتكم من
افاد او من مراكز ثانيه في عالم مسجله على
خيم على اساس مسجله يا زلمه
بعد ساعتين ونص
وسجل لك على هذه كمان هون يعني شيء حالي
يرسلها
واولادها اثنين
كلياتها
شكل مبدا الى العالم
احمد احمد احكي لي انت كيف انصبت ولا كنت
طالع من البيت انا نزلت برات البيت وقع
علي الحيط والباب الحمد لله على سلامتك
الله يسلمك الحمد لله على سلامتك هلا كيف
الوضع الحمد لله بخير وين اسعفوك
تميت اربعه ايام وبعدين رحت انا
وين اهلي
ووالده متوفي
هلا شلون بدكم هون بيتنا نزل على الارض ما
عندنا
هاي الخيمه كلها تكون عايشين فيها مع بعض
كم شخص عم تنام هون خمسه عشرين ثلاثين شخص
يعني بالخيمه
مثل هون سبعه من تنفوس عنده هذا الحرمه
هاي اللي هبط بيتها خيمه عرفت علي شلون
ابو كمان هدول اللي هبط بيتهم راح خيو
كمان خيمه العالم كلها في حرمه ارمله وهاي
كمان جاي هلا
عرفت علي شلون هاي اغراض هذول الجماعه
يعني كمان ثلاثه اربعه في واحد اجاني هلا
قبل بخمس دقايق